je risque et donc brasserie d'allant
beaucoup de préparatifs on a bien reçu
la marchandise qui est déjà un bon point
elle ajouté lors du déballage et on a
hâte d'être à demain pour pour commencé
à exposer les projets et booster apprend
la réunion donc c'est parti on va
proposer donc la première qui est la
bière aux pays bas c'est avec du houblon
réunionnais donc qui est la dernière
nouveauté de la brasserie qui est
présente pour l'instant que sur le salon
on présente également une blanche au
gingembre frais et la dernière c'est une
bière blanche brassac de la mangue et de
la vanille donc on a utilisé au maximum
des produits réunionnais et on espère qu
on espère que ça va plaire avec ça à
faire sur ce salon en termes de volume
ça donne
ça donne trois palettes de fûts et une
bouteille donc donc ça fait quand même
pas mal des bières on est à peu près à
2008 un peu plus c'est notre première
participation donc difficile d'estimer
les volumes et
la consommation ici donc on verra bien
ce que la première participation et
j'espère pas la dernière on a confiance
en notre produit donc l'emplacement et
hop
été préparé par tout le monde donc donc
a priori n'y a pas de raison
que ça se passe pas très bien perdre
bien merci